you would think at this point there's
nothing left to make us uncomfortable
you'd be wrong we have not gotten naked
in a long time so I guess it's back to
the basics bathing suits can make you
feel sexy they can also make you feel
super objectified good that we're doing
this because women have to wear
ridiculous swimsuits all the time you
have to have a lot of confidence to pull
your body out there like that luckily I
do okay oh this is just like a speedo
nope they forgot about the butt
hey I don't like that this is where
we're starting you know why else an
dad's gonna love this it's red I love
red it's my favorite color because red
rhymes with Ned when you're wearing a
thing that had your butt open hanukkah's
your butthole it looks like a very
normal speedo
this is the definition of business in
the front and party in the back
keep on spinning like suspenders for
your butt all I can think of when I wear
this is Ned which is really disturbing
you can play that are these boobs or
butts I would try and get into the pool
as quickly as possible
nobody look at my butt nobody look at my
butt doesn't that look like boobs
doesn't that tell me that doesn't look
like good men don't get enough
opportunities to have cleavage what's it
like to squat completely
you dropped something had to bend down
pick it up your pot would be like Puss
would Bob there's a lot of things in the
water you don't want to give them an
extra orifice to like discover I'm
looking for something that will make me
feel more uncomfortable than being naked
on spin and right now this makes me feel
great this is the Borat does it matter
which side is the front of the back
because they both look impossibly tiny
what even is this oh can fill this dick
pocket oh that's just pulling my dick up
is it supposed to go up your butt is
this supposed to be a thong and
unexpected but not unrealistic making
this video you shouldn't be able to do
that no one this is gross back is really
of all the things for the staffer to
cover why are the nipples the thing if
you're a woman you're very stressed out
about keeping your bits covered I think
one should have their nipples out
without judgment it's revolting I've
never found myself revolting before and
I've vomited on myself
the shape is cool it does emphasize a
man's V when you go swimming your pants
usually come off that way here boom oh
no all eyes are leading straight to the
moneymaker I mean I definitely feel
objectified so mission accomplished
this is like the lease with the body
holder so you're not pulling your dog's
neck this is getting some kinky [ __ ]
first things first let's let that string
disappear inside my butt crack it's gone
forever
one size fits some people very fine line
between my dick going tomorrow and my
dick going yes we're cuz this is pulling
the front but I once oops I ball I kind
of wish I had this for prom that would
have made problem or interesting OOP see
sigh both this feels more like a sex
outfit that a swim outfit want this to
be a little side ball oh my goodness
there are kids at this Beach you know
what no shark is ever gonna think you're
a seal in this it's gonna be like ah I
feel like a very very revealing Butler
in a porn
I bet zach is feeling pretty cute right
now I kind of like this boys eyelid is
pretty funny master would you like your
cake today sir
you just threw me a headband this looks
like one leg of an outfit a penis
slingshot extra large I've heard about
this seen a lot of pictures it's just
not something you wear in public
also it's terrible fashion half my shaft
is out in one full nut just just hanging
out everything's just kind of like
leaning a bit it's all just what about
the pubic hair that you have because
you're a human you need to do some
serious manscaping if you want to wear
this why was this made I don't know why
are there serial killers I feel more
naked than if I were actually naked this
looks like a mistake it looks like a
piece of balloon you got caught in my
butt after it popped g-string nudists
hello hey hey honey I'm on a I'm on a
try guys group right now can I call you
back like my dick broke its wrist and
has to wear a slang for the month the
dick is what it's grabbing on to to stay
on and the dick is an elastic thing
itself
god forbid you get a boner in this dude
babe that's my wife I'll tell her about
it later hear it from another one it's a
bummer that I had to go this far to
realize how uncomfortable a bathing suit
might make you keel tada fixed it game
set match my final thought about this
one is even go call the guy I don't
think there's an intelligent conclusion
to be drawn from this if there's a
bathing suit that makes you feel good
about yourself and makes you feel sexy
that's awesome
but kiss definitely does not make me
feel comfortable if I went to a remote
beach where it's just me and my wife
heck yes I'd wear some of these way
better ways to feel and look sexy in
these swimsuits leave a little to the
imagination I think we're done
I just saw his ex penis sorry yeah I
accidentally showed Eugene my deck
already I can still see your guide no
it's you your dick is out I like that we
sort of look like awful Power Rangers no
we do look like the power yeah really
awful once I hate this one I hate this
video you look so handsome but my butt
ate way more of that string than yours